Oh
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to GD 50 lecture
2 this is breakout and interestingly
cs50 has a history with breakout so I
pulled this up today this is pset 3 in
2015
2014 was an implementation of breakout
using the stanford portable library
which was a sort of java library that we
were able to get c bindings for and so
students were able to actually implement
a game in the what was at the time the
cs50 appliance which is a linux distro
but suffice to say that was a oh and a
funny story also i happened to also
write the lasers for this implementation
back in the day and i think that was one
of the first bits of code i got my hands
dirty with when working with cs50 so
today in the context of breakout we'll
be talking about a few different things
that we haven't talked about yet sprite
sheets being chief among them most
likely at least the most visibly so-so
sprite sheets are simply a way of taking
an image a large image and rather than
splitting it or rather than loading
individual images for all of your
different things in the game whether
it's your your aliens your you know your
paddles or whatnot you can put
everything into one sheet and then just
sort of index into that sheet using
rectangles quads we'll talk about soon
which will allow you to just draw a
subset of that image and therefore
condense all of your artwork just into
one piece of one file we'll be talking a
little bit more about procedural
generation in the context of breakout
and in this case we'll be laying out all
the bricks in the game world
procedurally so having instead of the
same set of colors in this case the
standard layout is to have a bunch of
the same colored bricks row by row
well actually implement a dynamic
generation approach and have a bunch of
different cool layouts we'll see and
it's actually quite simple to achieve
pretty believable results well managed
state a little bit better in this game
so before we sort of had a couple public
there are global variables and we didn't
really have the concept of like a per
state or a global state that we were
cleanly sort of sharing but between all
of our states for our state machine but
to avoid having sort of like a polluted
global namespace and to just sort of
keep things a little bit cleaner will
end up taking all the important
variables for our code like
the player and any other entities that
bricks the ball and rather than keep
them in our main that Lua will end up
shifting them well will serve transfer
them to and from the different states
via the state machines enter method will
actually have levels so a progression
system so start at level one go up and
then with each level will implement a
scale on in terms of the generation of
the of the bricks so we'll get higher
tiered bricks and more points as a
result we'll have a health system so
Hart's in a similar fashion to the
Legend of Zelda particle systems which
are a very important aesthetic component
to 2d games in 3d games come particle
systems basically being a bunch of
spawned images that you sort of cluster
you put into a little spawner emit them
in a certain way and color them make
perform math on them and get sort of
believable effects like fire and smoke
and all these other things that would
otherwise be sort of not easy to do
using simple animation but trivial with
a particle system will do a little bit
more complicated collision detection
with our paddle and with our bricks than
we did with pong and then we'll also
talk lastly about how we can save data
locally to our computer so that when we
close the application and run it again
we end up having a persistent high score
rather than just something that's
volatile so first though I would like to
demo today's finished game so if anybody
would like to demo from the audience
that would be nice
go ahead come up go ahead and cue it up
for you
what's your name Jerri Jerri Colton to
meet you so we're going to go ahead and
run break out here
[Music]
and so it uses the arrow keys so if you
go ahead and press up and down you'll
see you can move between the start and
the high scores screen these are two
separate screens so go ahead and here we
have when you start you can choose a
paddle so rather than just the same old
paddle every time you get to select and
as you can see here he chose green so we
gets the green paddle these bricks all
procedure generated so if he reruns the
application they'll be completely
different and as is the classic formula
the ball moves between the bricks and
the paddle when it hits a brick if it's
of a certain color it'll either get
destroyed in this case if it's blue it's
the base color Rick so it's the lowest
value and if it's higher than blue it'll
end up going down a color depending on
which color it is I believe that goes
blue green red purple yellow so anything
higher will get shifted down and in the
player amasses points as you can see top
right score and notice also the 3 hearts
that'll be the player's health so if he
were to lose on purpose possibly we can
see he gets back he gets another message
uh saying
press ENTER to serve his hearts have
gone down by once and I was got 2 out of
3 health and so eventually if he were to
by chance lose completely
oh that's honestly the most fun part
about breakout is just getting it caught
in a bunch of stuff but you can see we
go to a game over screen it shows your
final score and then you can press ENTER
and it'll oh I must have had a bug but
that should take you back to the
infinite in the event that you have a
high-score it'll take you to enter a
high score and if you take it if you
don't have a high score it'll take you
back to the Start menu so made a couple
last-minute changes unfortunately I must
have left something in there but that's
breakout in a nutshell our goal today
will be to implement basically all the
functionality we saw oh we didn't take a
look at the high score screen so let's
take a look at that really quick as well
so here at the title you can see we have
start in high scores click oh man okay I
must have screwed something up so I'm
gonna go as you break out 12 okay
sorry I apologize I'm going to fix that
but it should show this menu here where
you will have a list of all your names
that get loaded from a file and will
output your score accordingly and in the
event that you get a new high score
you'll get to enter your name after that
and then it'll end up saving it to
another file and I'll when we get to
that point I'll try and fix it so that
we can actually see what it looks like
so let's go back to these slides here so
this is the overall state flow of our
game so as you can see by me marking it
out in a highlighted color we start off
in the start state and this is all stuff
we've covered before just a state
machine it's a little bit more
complicated than flappy bird that we
have one two three four five six so in
eight states as opposed to I think it
was four or five in the last lecture and
the arrows illustrate which states can
move in between other states so as we
saw the start state can move via the up
and down arrows in the high score State
it can move between the high score state
and back so when you go into the high
score State press escape go back to the
start State the high score the start
state also has an arrow branching off to
the left going down to the paddle select
state where we saw the user is able to
select a paddle to use once they've
selected a paddle we'll go to the serve
state they'll be able to serve the ball
at their leisure and then it'll go back
and forth between the play States so if
they end up like taking damage the ball
goes below the surface of
screen they'll go back to the surf state
again so they can reorient themselves if
they're in the play state and they end
up scoring clearing the whole entire set
of bricks they'll actually get taken to
the victory state and the victory states
where we increment the level and we also
regenerate the level and then the
victory state goes back to the serve
state and then we repeat that whole loop
again in the play state if they are to
get a game over they'll go to the game
over state it'll tell them their score
and then they'll go to the enter high
score state depending on whether they
have a high score and if not as seen by
the arrow that goes up and to the left
they'll actually go back to the start
state and then the enter high score
state will also go back to the high
score state so that they can see once
they've entered their high score their
score relative to the other scores in
the list so in breakout zero which we're
going to look at now we're going to do
some very basic stuff so this is the day
zero update as always I'm in breakout
zero right now yes I am so what we're
gonna do is I'm going to look at first
thing here line twenty seven so before
what we were doing in our application is
having basically a lot of files at the
top level and sort of losing track of
what we were doing potentially
especially as you start adding more and
more files and you've got like 50 100
more files that's something that's
obviously not maintainable so the
solution there just put them in folders
and then keep track of everything keep
them organized and that's a major thing
that we're gonna start doing and on top
of that we're also going to in our code
keep things a little bit more modular
and that's why we have this file source
slash dependencies which we'll take a
look at in a second we've allocated a
bunch of global tables here so we're
taking the design decision of even
though I mentioned that we will be sort
of taking a lot of the global variables
out of our application assets we're
gonna keep all of those in some global
variables and we'll see in the future
how we can maybe implement a resource
manager class that takes care of this
for us but for now for simplicity sake
in love load we're just going to have a
few global tables that contain in this
case global fonts so by key we can rent
index small medium and large fonts which
are just new fonts at different sizes
eight sixteen thirty-two and we're using
it we have a fonts folder now instead of
just keeping it at the parent level
we're gonna set it to small we have
global textures so background main
arrows hearts particle so we have the
background which was the background of
our screen main has all of our bricks
paddles the balls etc arrows are gonna
be for the paddle selection the two left
and right arrows hearts are gonna be for
our health and then particle is a single
small tiny little texture that will use
to spawn all the particles and our
particle systems later on as we get
towards the end of the demonstration so
this is push we're setting it up just
like normal nothing new there except the
virtual width virtual height and all
that stuff those have been moved out if
we look into source in a constants file
so this file here instead of having all
of the constants in main it kind of
makes sense just to like take them out
put them in a file called constants not
Lua and we can sort of manage all that
look at we we can know immediately when
we're looking at Capitol window width
window height etc these are all
constants if you have a constants file
we just keep more easily track it rather
than having to grep through all of our
files to try and figure out what we were
looking at and the constants are indexed
here are used here in our setup screen
as before and then another sounds global
table just as before we have a bunch of
different sound effects I've separated
the music from the sound effects just
too so that we can see at a glance oh
this is the music these are the sound
effects pretty straightforward we have a
state machine as always and we're just
gonna use a start state for this
demonstration setting it to start love
dot resize love to update these are all
functions we've seen before nothing too
new level Obul input table so as in flat
of the case of flappy bird we can index
into that input table anywhere in our
application and call Lev keyboard that
was pressed key which allows us to take
input exclusively from main and use it
in other modules here we're drawing the
so this is the actual rendering code and
we're doing this in our love draw as
opposed to a specific state because this
is actually gonna apply to all states
we're always gonna have this background
so rather than duplicate it over and
over again in this instance this minor
bit of code we're gonna display the
background in the behind this the behind
all the states so all the states are
gonna render over this background and
make it seem a little more cohesive
we're gonna draw at zerozero without
rotation and then this bit of math here
the virtual width divided by and then
background with minus one will end up
being a scale factor so that we can
always scale it to be our virtual width
because the texture by default is some
amount smaller than our actual window or
our actual virtual width and height but
by dividing virtual width by whatever
the background width of that images by
one we'll get a scale factor because
virtual width is larger than the image
we'll get a scale factor on x and y that
equates to it completely stretching to
fill our our virtual width and height
and recall that these two parameters are
the scale on the x and the y so it's
gonna be some like one point something
or two point something whatever it takes
to end up filling the screen and then
lastly here the new bid I implemented is
just a display frames per second
function which i think is kind of
important generally and it's very easy
to do
I don't recall I don't think we talked
about it yet but just love that timer
get FPS and then I just draw in the top
left in green so that we can see it
throughout all of our iterations of the
game what are frames per second are if
you want to monitor without having to
look through your terminal or anything
like that just displaying it at the top
its standard practice in a lot of games
if you've gone to the debug console or
whatnot or sort of looked into some of
the hacks you'll see that in a lot of
places so I talked earlier about
dependencies lua so this is this ties in
as well to our effort to sort of
modularize everything keep everything
organized instead of requiring
everything at the top of main let's just
put it all in a file and then we'll know
add a click at a glance while requiring
and we don't have to look look through
main and make main you know hundred
lines but actually a lot more than it
needs to be so requiring push requiring
class same as we've done before require
a source dot constants we have access to
those require state machine and then
base state and start state so let's go
ahead and take a look at our start state
so I put states in a subfolder of source
this is another effort to sort of keep
things modular in this particular
project we won't have a lot of nested
folders of code but I decided to put the
states in their own folder just so
easily you can get access to all your
states so we'll look at start state here
on line 21 so recall in the start state
we just had breakout in the center of
the screen and we had start game and
high scores so the user was able to
highlight which state he wanted to look
at so we need to keep track of which
ones highlighted so all this variables
purpose is just to keep track so one or
two one being play game and two being
high scores and then here if we're if we
press up and down then we because
there's only two options effectively you
can just flip whatever highlight it is
with one or two if you have a list of
options that's more than two then you'll
need to increment one until it gets to
whatever X is your number of list
options and then if you press down at
that point you should flip back up to
the top and the same holds true for
whether you're at option 1 you should
flip up to you should go flip rotate to
the bottom of your list so that it looks
as if you've gone all the way around and
then we're just playing a sound here
when we do that we have a love keyboard
let's press escape call here it's not
global anymore because there are some
states in our application or we might
want to press escape to actually go
backwards and we'll see that
and so rendering here we render break
out with a large font now that we can
access G fonts at large key in the
center of the screen set medium font and
then if we're gonna render our two text
fields one after the other but if
highlighted is equal to one then we're
gonna set it to some blue color which is
103 255 255 255 and then render it and
then make sure to reset the color after
that because recall love 2d is a sort of
like a state machine in its own right
where if you set the color to something
whatever you draw and render after that
via images or text will adopt that color
so having everything be 255 255 255 255
which is pure white completely opaque
has the effect of drawing everything
completely opaque but if you don't do
that your images or whatnot that you
draw afterwards will be tinted or
transparent which you most of the time
don't want but you might sometimes want
that and we'll actually see that in the
paddle select state and same thing holds
true here if highlighted is to do the
exact same thing and so if you run this
application which
is mainly just a subset of what we saw
before we can move up and down between
start and high scores but if we press
ENTER on any of them
nothing happens because we have no event
handlers actually taking care of that
but we have the image scaled to the
screen we have breakout in the middle
and we have our two menu options there
so breakout one so this is this is where
we start to dive a little bit into
sprite sheets which is a major component
of game development 2d game development
that we will be looking at in the future
and in this application but a sprite
sheet is just ultimately rather than
have you know I don't know how many
images are on this sprite sheet here but
however many of these files just have
one file put them all together and then
using rectangles define where the
different sprites are and then when we
want to draw use those rectangles and
just tell love dog graphics top draw I
want you to draw this texture of the
sprite sheet but I want you to draw just
this section of it you'd pass it in a
quad which is just simply a rectangle
with height x and y and love 2d well no
okay I'm gonna draw the image but only
this bit and it has the effect of
looking as if you're only drawing tiny
little images as opposed to one
monstrous image and the functions that
are relevant for us to look at our love
dog graphics new quad which takes an X Y
width and a height and also a dimensions
object which you get from an image we'll
see that and all that basically is I
believe is just an X Y width and height
as well or just a width and a height
rather from an from an from whatever
image you want to create quads for and
then love dog graphics draw we've
already seen it but this is a different
signature this has texture quad XY quad
being the second argument and when it
when it takes in this quad it knows to
only draw that defined rectangle of
image to the screen and so we'll go
ahead and take a look now at breakout
one
the question was are there any tools so
that we don't have to guess where the
quad is when we're doing the sheet yes
there are a lot of the time I looked and
saw a couple but I haven't tested them
thoroughly myself for simpler examples
like this it's usually easy enough to
programmatically do it but yeah when you
get into having giant sprite atlases
where you have especially things that
are not necessarily symmetrical or
rectangular looking even though they
still need to be defined rectangular Li
it's often best to to use a tool like
that there are I do believe I just
haven't I haven't used them I can bring
it up in a future lecture and so we can
discuss any other questions before we
carry into breakout one all right so I'm
going to go ahead and open up the very
first thing we should look out in
breakout one in the source directory we
have a new file and from here on out I'm
gonna assume we're gonna always assume
that we when we introduce a new file
we're going to include it in
dependencies lua and so in this case all
we need to do is just say require source
slash util and as you can see we're also
adding a place date to this
demonstration but from here on out I
won't make mention of us actually adding
it to our project so you told Lua is the
module that contains the code that we're
gonna use to actually generate quads for
a given sprite sheet and this function
all it does is it takes in what's an
atlas or sprite sheet the the names are
synonymous you'll hear on both or we
pass it an atlas we pass it the width of
the tile that we want and the height of
the tile that we want it's gonna get the
width and the height of the sheet here
so every image has a function called get
width and get height so we're just gonna
do that and specifically the sheet width
and sheet height are the width of the
image divided by tile width and tile
height so we know how many times we need
to iterate over the sprite sheet to
generate a rectangle we're dividing it
up based on the size of our tiles
and then we just basically do a simple
nested for loop here we start a counter
and a sprite sheet the sprite sheet is
going to be a table that holds all of
our quads we just say 4y gets 0 sheet
height minus 1 so starting at the top
left going down and starting at the r
and starting at the top going down and
then x equals 0 starting at the left
going right at sprite sheet sheet
counter which is one here because in lua
tables are 1 indexed we're going to
create a new quad at x times tile width
y times tile with give it the width and
the height of our tile so just whatever
we passed into our function signature
here it'll often be in this case be 16
by 32 because that's the size of the
bricks and then we pass in the last
parameter that we saw in the slide which
is Atlas : get dimensions and then we
just increment our sheet counter here
and then at the end of this one we're
all done we'll return this it will have
a table of quads that we can then use
that are you know sort of 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 well I should say 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 top
left to bottom right of all the sprites
in our sheet to make it super easy to
look at we have another function here
Lua doesn't by default have a slice
function but we're just adding to it
table dot slice it takes the table a
first the first entry in the table that
we want the last entry and then the step
between them just like pythons slice
function it just iterates over the ADA
for loop which is first SIL 1 so 1 by
default until the last or until the
whatever this this sort of number sign
is the size of a table which I don't
think we've introduced yet but basically
this is if we pass in last
it'll stop there otherwise just assume
we want the whole entire table and then
this comma here at the end which has
step or 1 you can pass in a step at the
end of a for loop as a third argument
and that'll be however much it
increments or decrements the
loop that you're in so by default it's
just one we go one and we go to two then
we go to three but you can set it to
negative one and so if you say four I
gets three to one minus one
you'll go three to one and you can you
can't do it normal normally a step and
just which is what we do here or you
know you can do a step but you can't
slice which is why we have here sliced
at number of slice plus one gets table I
and then eventually we return slice so
it just returns just a segment of
whatever table we're in and then the
important function here that we're
actually going to use in our application
we're going to generate quads paddles
and so this takes x + y 0 and 64 and if
we look back at our paddles here we can
see that we have various different sizes
so we have a small one a medium one a
large one and then a really large one so
if we want to get every single paddle in
our sprite sheet small medium large
giant notice that we have four blocks
and within each of those blocks we have
four different sizes so we can just
iterate over this four times and then
just define whatever this the size of
this rect is that wrecked that rect and
that rect and we'll see the math for it
here if I go 0 2 3 4 I get 0 till 3
we're gonna go ahead because there's
that that'll give us 4 so that's how
many times we want to iterate over the
spritesheet to get the separate quads
we'll get the smallest one so quads
counter we initialize counter to one
gets love graphics out new quad at X Y
width of 32 and 16 o and x and y default
at 0 and 64 here because the note recall
that the these are all 16 tall here so
we're starting Y at 64 so that we start
right here and we're starting at X is
zero because it's on the left side so
we'll do that we'll increment counter
get it at the 32 wide by 16 tall those
are the actual dimensions of the
smallest one the same exact logic
applies for medium and for large only
that we're adding 32 and then we're make
it's i-64 and then we're adding 96 to X
at size 96 because they're getting wider
but they're also offsetting more to the
right and then the last bit is pretty
much the same thing as before except now
we're going y plus 16 back to X because
we've gone down a row in our sprite
sheet the the paddle width at that point
is 128 but still 16 pixels and then here
at the bottom because we want to do this
four times and we want to go through the
chunks are effectively 32 pixels because
we're going 16 16 16 16 we're just gonna
add 32 to Y and then go to the next set
of four paddles so this is how we're
effectively getting all of the paddle
sprites and are gonna be stored 1
through X where I believe X is 16 so
we'll have 16 quads defined in our
sprite sheet there after that we can
then return so I'm gonna go back to main
dalawa now on line 64 here we have a new
global table called G frames we'll be
able to access us anywhere we want to
draw stuff and it's just the same thing
that we just saw generate quads paddles
and we just pass it in our main texture
and our main texture is this this is
what our main texture looks like and
then we're going to index it we're gonna
say it gets the key paddles because in
that particular table was just the quads
for our paddles so in the future we just
need to call love graphics draw texture
and then index into G frames paddles at
whatever paddle we want and that's how
we can keep track of what we want to
draw a paddle wise and in this
particular demo we have a new paddle
class because paddle is a thing in our
game we can represent it as sort of a
class or an object so we'll define a
class for it everything's pretty simple
thus far gets an X and a Y DX 0 with
height skin the skin is going to be what
color it is we need to keep track of
that and then the size because the size
will be how we sort of offset into our
paddles our quads because the sizes are
small medium large
giant one two three four times four so
one two three four for the first set and
then five six seven eight for the second
set those are all sorted by color so we
can just multiply skin times we can
multiply whatever our sizes by skin and
that will give us the current Frank the
current quad that we want in order to
draw to the screen and then on line
seven so this is a keyboard input here
stuff that we've seen before if the if
it's if we're pressing a left or right
then the paddle should move the DX
should be set left or right we want to
clamp it we saw this that we've seen
this as well clamp the input to the left
and the right side of the screen if the
DX is less than zero do math up max and
math up man
otherwise if we're moving to the right
and then here this is actually where we
tie it all together and we actually use
the quads to draw something onto the
screen so we're calling love that
graphics that draw just our texture are
our main texture and then G frames at
paddles at our current size which is two
we want to by default have the medium
size plus four times whatever our skin
is minus one so if our skin is one we'll
add we won't add which is the blue skin
we won't add anything to it it'll just
be four times zero but if we have the
next one it'll be two minus one so we'll
end up adding four to that and because
we're adding four to it times whatever
that skin is it'll just basically put us
four quads in which is the next the
exact same paddle but the next color and
then lastly what we'll look at here is
the play state so we had just the start
state before but now we want to actually
test to make sure we can draw a paddle
move it around the screen so we're gonna
implement a simple play state here so on
line 20 we're just calling self dot
paddle gets paddle or initializing a new
paddle object and then we're keeping
track of all so this is a simple like
pause demonstration if self dot paused
then
actually yeah I don't did I say it's up
top paused I do okay I just don't
initialize it to anything up here
you should set I should have set self
DUP self dot pause to false here if self
dot paused then we're gonna test to see
whether we're pressing space and if we
are unpause it otherwise basically just
do the same exact thing in Reverse if
we're if we press space pause the game
plays sound etc here on line 39 we're
just gonna call update on the paddle
which just remember tests for left or
right input here we want to be able to
escape the game so we're just gonna have
a handler for escape render the paddle
on lines 47 which will do the love duck
graphics draw with a quad as we saw
before but it'll use the skin and the
size of that paddle to index into the
quads tile sheet appropriately and then
here if we're paused let's just draw
some text in the middle of the screen
that just says pause and we use the
large font so we can go ahead and demo
this now and see everything come
together we have as before our start
state but if we press enter now we go to
our place state and we just have a
paddle at the bottom of the screen it's
size two skin one just the blue skin and
we can move it left or right like that
and we hits the right side left side of
the screen it'll stop and it hits the
right side of the screen
it'll stop as well so we've made
progress but this is one of the
fundamental things I'd like to showcase
today is just like using quads and
categorizing them organizing them and
being able to draw your assets from a
large compiled image rather than you
know keep track of however many images
it would take and you have to name all
of them and sort them it would just be
it would just be a big pain so yeah
definitely going forward when you have
more than one sprite you want to sort of
put it together in one sheet and that's
how we can accomplish that
but we don't have bricks and this is
probably the other big main component of
breakout besides the paddle and the ball
we want to have bricks that we can
actually hit and aim for on the screen
so this update will address that so
let's go ahead and take a look at
breakout - in main Lua open it up here
on line 66 you can see we have a new
table in our G frames because we had one
for just four paddles we took out just
the paddles from our sprite sheet we're
gonna do the same thing for just the
balls so we're gonna look at if we look
here we can see that the ball sort of
come after all of the bricks here and
they're just laid out in eight pixels
wide by 8 pixels tall little increments
here so four pixels to one brick - or
four balls to one brick two balls two
one
whereas horizontally and then two bolts
vertically and so what we'll end up
doing is just a simple function in our
util it takes a look at that so let's go
ahead and take a look at our util da lua
which we've made changes to
and so what this is going to do is sort
of do the same thing that we did before
it has to iterate so we have to notice
we have two rows of balls we have these
four and then we have these three so we
want to iterate four times we want to
find whatever the offset is here the X
and the y so it looks like three times
32 and then three times 16
so 96 by I can't do math whatever 16
times 3 is and then we'll end up 48 and
then we'll have which is what we do here
so we have two iterations so a four loop
that goes from 0 to 3 so the for the top
row the 4 instead of counter to 1 here
notice also 96 and 48 that's the X and
the y that we're setting that's the
where the offset is for the individual
ball sprites quads at counter gets and
notice also quads as a table we're going
to return this quads that counter gets
loved out graphics new quad at XY 8
pixels wide a pixels tall that's how
large the balls are and then we're going
to add 8 to it at because we're going to
the right so this iteration just goes
left to right and then here we're gonna
do basically X being set to 96 and then
Y to 56 and then because we were editing
X directly in here we want to reset X
back to 96 but then also add the 8
pixels so that we have the start for the
next row vertically so on the at Y 56 do
the exact same here thing here but only
do it three times because there call
there was four balls on top and then
three balls on bottom and then return it
at the very end and so now we have just
an individual table we don't need to
keep like one monstrous table of quads
which I find sort of disorganized we can
just have a table of frames for the
paddles and the balls and the bricks as
we'll see actually I have it up here I
think maybe not
so in bald Oh actually hold on sorry so
we were looking at I skipped over this
one on accident so the balance update so
everything everything I just said is is
relevant but accidentally hit roulette
right two times we want to go to the
balance update because this is a
slightly simpler so we were just talking
about the ball which is perfect so if
we're gonna take the ball and then we're
gonna add that to the scene and we're
just going to implement bouncing off the
walls
so actually pretty identical to the code
we saw for pong where you just detect
whether the ball has gone past the left
right or top edge of the screen in this
case it'll also allow us to go to the
bottom of the screen and will also
implement colliding with the paddle so
we can get a sense of the actual
gameplay and what that feels like so
everything is currently current so we're
gonna go after talking about the
function to actually get the individual
ball quads out of the spritesheet we're
gonna look at the ball class which is
going to allow us to spawn them in our
scene so a ball takes a width and a
height of eight no velocity but we're
gonna allow ourselves to initialize the
ball with the skin and we'll see this
later
just as a cutesy little thing to use the
actual individual sprites rather than
just one constant sprite we're just
gonna give it a random number between
one and seven because there are seven
quads and then we'll just use G frames
balls that math dot random number to get
the end of two actual ball sprint that
we want and so we have a simple collides
function within ball what allow us to
check to see whether we've collided with
something that has a XY width and a
height so it's a simple it's a simple
AABB collision detection and then here
we have reset just resets it's the
middle of screen update applies velocity
stuff we've already seen this is where
we actually implement bouncing off the
walls so if X is less than or equal to
zero greater than equal to virtual with
-8 or less than or equal to zero this
should be where we reverse the velocity
in the case of it bouncing off the left
side we want to reverse the X velocity
but keep it going up if it is the top
then we want
reverse the Y velocity would keep it
moving in whatever direction it was
moving and same thing with the
right-hand wall so and then play a wall
hit sound and we're incorporating the
sound sort of as we go today just
because they're so simple and it's also
kind of nice just to have a little bit
of feedback when you're actually
employing the game and the exact same
code is here for drawing so we have main
texture but now we're using G frames
balls and then we're using or indexing
that at self dot skin and recall that we
just set self dot skin in here so all we
need to do just make it random is just
whenever we create a new ball
just give it a map out random seven and
then that'll index into that quads table
so we can draw a different ball texture
each time and so let's go ahead and see
Oh actually no and one last thing we
need to look at is the play state has a
little bit of new code as well we're
going to spawn a ball so this is where
we do it here I'm not doing it random
but I could do it random here if I
wanted to I could do math out random
seven and every time we boot up the game
is gonna be a different color because
it's gonna be a different skin we need
to update the ball so on line 50 we just
update it like we do the paddle and then
on line 52 we're just testing to see
whether it collides with the paddle
because we're using just simple AABB if
it collides with the paddle we can
assume it was coming down we can just
reverse as Delta Y now does anybody know
what might be a current issue with the
current implementation of this function
particularly with this line
it will you're on the right track the
quite the answer was if the ball is
coming from the side it won't
necessarily be bounced back up in the
right y-direction if it's coming from
the side it'll always in this case be
coming from up above so it'll always
still be reversing in the right Delta Y
but what's gonna happen if it comes in
at an angle and then isn't basically
reset like if the record right now if it
comes in at an angle and it gets like
caught let's say it's like below the top
edge of the of the paddle you're gonna
get in it you're gonna get an infinite
collision loop because we're not
resetting its position we're only
updating its velocity if it comes in at
the right angle from the side it's going
to get stuck inside the inside the pedal
and then it's gonna cause a little bit
of funky behavior I'll try and see if I
can make that happen in my demonstration
here but that's the gist of all these
updates so if we go to start we can see
immediately we have a ball and then when
it hits the sides or the top it bounces
accordingly it has the paddle so when it
comes in from the top flush on the top
it it flips the Y velocity let's see if
I can get it at an angle here oh there
it is it'll get stuck and so whenever
you sort of do a a BB collision
detection just remember to always reset
the position of whatever it is that
collided that's moving so that it
doesn't clip and get stuck inside of
something else over and over again yes
the question is I'm always doing a love
space dot and as opposed to just running
things from using the complete path of
whatever the file is in order to do that
so are you on a Mac or a Windows machine
so if you're on earth so on a Windows
machine it is a little trickier but I
found a really nice sort of plug in 4 vs
code so if using vs code which is the
editor that I use that has plugins and
one of the plugins that you can download
is for love 2d and it has it config
where if you just press alt L it will
run your whatever directory you're
currently in whatever project are
currently in it'll it'll call love it
adds it to your path for you so download
the love to deep Luggin on vs code if
you want that to work I'm on a Mac so I
can edit what's called my bash profile
and alias love to its complete path in
my file system and you could do the same
thing with I don't know how it would
work with Windows in terms of aliasing
but it's essentially the same thing as
typing out the entire path to love but
only I'm changing it to another word I'm
changing it to love so I'm setting love
equals to application slash love app
/contents less resources etc so good
question I would download on Windows I'm
a big fan of vs code and the left to
deep lug in I would recommend looking
into that and I'm sure there are other
plugins and there's a page also on the
website I don't have a browser open at
the moment but on and on the wiki you
can look at getting the getting started
page I believe it's like love to decom
slash wiki slash getting started they
have a bunch of instructions for
different operating systems and
different text editors that allow you to
get sort of a more efficient workflow
going so any other questions
all right so we did the bounce update
now we can finally edit the bricks add
add in the bricks I should say so these
are pretty simple so we're going to take
a look at it and right now we're not
going to do any sort of fancy procedural
generation we're just going to get some
bricks on the screen just some easy
bricks or rather we will get some very
basic procedural generation but not to
the level that we'll see soon we'll see
that very soon okay so I'm gonna go into
my main.lua here I'm gonna go into the
breakout 3 and same thing that we did
before on line 67 we just have a new
bricks table in our G frames and just
generate quads bricks we call from utila
WA so we can look at that really quick
as well this one's actually really easy
source utila wa because they start at
the very top of the screen we can assume
that we could we could we could
effectively treat this whole thing as if
it were just these and just do generate
quads at a constant width and height
because effectively we only need a
subset of the frames it's generating
because it's generating them this way
top to bottom left to right we can just
grab all the way up to here using table
dot slice which we saw before and not
worry about indexing into any weird like
having any constants X&Y that we need to
index with in order to get an offset we
can just do a very simple if we go down
to line 57 generate quads bricks it just
does a table dot slice and so within
that we're gonna generate quads atlas 32
16 so this is gonna have the effect of
dividing up our sprite sheet by 32 by 16
pieces it's gonna generate all of these
just fine but then it's gonna have quads
here here here here here that don't line
up with the quads that you see here
because it's just blindly assuming that
all of the the sprites in that sheet are
the same size because it's all we're
doing we're just calling generate quads
which if you recall just generates a
fixed size width and height throughout
our entire atlas
which is great for a lot of sheets that
are symmetrical but there are cases
where we have like for example here
where our sprite sheet is asymmetrical
we have paddles of different sizes we
have the balls which are eight by eight
we have the bricks we have the we have
the other power-ups at the bottom but
the generate quads bricks takes in that
the table that we're generating which is
going to be a bunch of frames that we
don't want many of them clipped have
clipped and then we're going to take it
from one to twenty one and when we do
that one to twenty one is effectively
that's how many of these there are so
eighteen and then one two three so from
one to twenty one
all of those that'll be all the bricks
we can throw away all the rest of the
quads and just blindly assume that
they're all the same size so any
questions on how quads or how any of
these tables are working okay cool so
we're going to go ahead we have a new
class now brick Lua so simple building
blocks in brick dalawa on line 30 we
have a flag called
in play so if that in play gets true and
so we're just gonna use this to render
it we're just gonna say if it's in play
render it if it's not don't render it
that simple that way we won't have to
worry about object D allocation or
anything fancy we have all of our bricks
and whether it's in play or not render
it or perform update logic and you know
if it's not in play just pretend it
doesn't exist just ignore it
we're only gonna have like 30 or I'll I
don't know how many 13 max by 4 bricks
and our scene at once so worrying about
freeing memory isn't really an issue but
if you have you know a million different
things getting generated all the time
having simple in play is false might not
always be viable because you need to
store all that memory for all those
objects so just a shorthand a shortcut
here but not necessarily best practice
for very large games but certainly
certainly great and simple for small
games
on line 37 we define a function called
brick hit and all this does is just play
a sound effect and set in plate of false
and so all we're gonna do is just check
to see whether there's a collision and
then just call this hit function play a
sound and then just pretend doesn't
exist anymore and then render all render
does is if it's in play
checking the in play flag draw main at
bricks they're using our bricks table
here that we created and then we're
gonna start at one and then we're going
to index it based on our color minus one
times four and then we're gonna add its
tier so there are if you recall one two
three four five colors and four tiers
and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna jump between the colors so we'll
go value one value to value three value
for value five that'll be our first five
or I guess six that'll be our first six
bricks and then we're going to go one
two three or we're gonna add we're gonna
have a tier basically it'll be one two
three or four and we're if it's at Tier
one then we can just add basically to
index into whatever tier we're on we
just need to add tier minus one to
whatever our index is so here for tier
is one then we just want to render this
block we don't want to go to the next
one so we're just going to say tier
minus one we're gonna add so two one
minus one is zero so we're gonna add
zero to this get this but if tiers to
we'll add one and two and three and then
we just multiply whatever brick we want
by our color well multiply it by four to
get an offset for whatever our actual
color is so we take our color figure out
where on the sheet it is and then just
add our tier to it
in order to index into our sprite sheet
accordingly and so that's what they the
math here is doing and if we go back to
our place date
and I'm going to start moving a little
bit faster just so we can keep caught up
but in our play state one thing that we
notice here we have a new class called
level maker that we're seeing which I'm
which we has a function called create
map we're gonna take out all the logic
for generating our levels and we're
gonna put it in one place we're gonna
call that level maker rather than in our
different class our different states
that maybe generate the bricks like the
play state or this I guess it would be
the serve state victory state I guess
rather than generating all the bricks in
that state within its you know it's init
code let's just make a level maker and
we can just say okay you know set bricks
to level maker dot create map which will
return a table of bricks same excuse me
logic as we saw before in this case
we're just going to iterate for K brick
in pairs of self dot bricks
if the bricks in play and it collides if
the ball collides with it then hit it
which will set it not into place so
simple AABB and then lastly we have our
render logic here which is going to take
that bricks table and just iterate over
it and the last thing we should probably
look at is the actual level maker itself
which in this case is very simple but
we'll see it gets a little bit more
complicated later when we do it we have
a very sort of a more elaborate
procedural generation approach to our
levels but right now we're just gonna
say set two random variables here number
of rows and columns and then for every
row or for basically every yeah every
row and then every column create a new
brick and then there's some math here
I'm gonna kind of skim over it but
basically it calculates where the brick
is and then gives us eight pixels of
padding on either side and then based on
how many it is it needs to Center all
the bricks and shift them by a certain
amount to the left and then start
drawing all of them and that's
essentially what this code does here so
calculate the center
I wrote it out in comments here but I'm
going to kind of just kind of glaze over
it for now but effectively Center all
the bricks basically calculate what
offset on the x-axis you need to put all
of them so that they appear centered and
then you're going to draw them all out
and then that's it for the level maker
class so simply number of rows and
columns and then fill a table with
bricks but set their X equal to however
much we need to Center all of them when
they're all drawn out so we need to
figure we need to basically take in our
number of columns into account we do
that and then if we go into breakout 3
and run that we have bricks they're
getting collided with and as soon as
they get hit collided gets our in play
on each of those bricks gets set to
false and they no longer get rendered
and they no longer get updated in terms
of collision and we still have the issue
with the the ball not getting reset will
fix that that's an easy fix but we're
coming a long way we have things moving
at quite a pace I'm gonna go ahead and
move to the next bit of code here so
this is another bit of code I'm gonna
sort of glaze over a little bit the
details here but at a high level what we
need to do is it's one thing to detect
that we've collided with a brick but in
breakout
the ball bounces off of the brick
depending on which side it hits and we
don't know this necessarily just based
off of the collision and we just know
whether the collision is true or not we
don't know where it came from
and where how much it collided with and
then we're also going to fix our paddle
so that rather than because currently
all it does is just negate whatever the
Y velocity is but we want to add a
little bit more variety to how we end up
sort of ricocheting the ball off the
paddle when we play so that we can sort
strategize a little bit and give
ourselves a little bit of game play so
if we are moving to the right and we hit
the right edge of the paddle with the
ball should probably go in a sharper
direction same thing with the left side
and we can effectively do that by taking
the middle figuring out how far away
from the center it is and then just
amplifying our Delta X in the negative
or positive direction based off of that
and that has the effect of causing that
to happen
so here we can see we have the ball sort
of coming at the paddle and let's
pretend that the paddle is moving to the
left in this case however far away the
ball is from the center we want to scale
that by some amount and then end up
making that our negative Delta X because
where that's effectively how the game
normally works if you move the paddle to
the left of the right hit it on a corner
or something gives it that sharp angle
and that's effective what the sharp
angle is it's just a strong Delta X and
it gets amplified the larger this is so
just basically take this multiply it by
some amount and then make it negative or
positive on your dy/dx that's your sort
of paddle collision v2 brick collision
is a little bit it's pretty simple but
it's a little bit more complicated
basically what we need to do is just
check and see which edge of the ball
isn't inside the ball inside the brick
and so if the left edge of the band we
can also sort of simplify this a little
bit if the left as you see here by the
pseudo-code if the left edge of the ball
is outside the brick and the DX is
positive then we can say oh we can
basically assume oh we've come in from
the left side so we should probably go
in the opposite y direction on the left
side or sorry we should go we should go
in the same y direction but negate our
Delta X because we're coming in from the
left the left side is outside the
outside the brick so bounce it back and
the same thing for the right edge and we
only need to do this test the left edge
of the ball if DX is positive because if
DX is negative there's no way the balls
colliding with the left side of our
brick so we can shortcut that
effectively we do the same exact logic
here just on the right edge of the brick
instead of the left edge and then if
none of those hold true we're gonna see
if the top edge of the ball is above the
top edge of the path of the brick and if
that's the case we know that we've hit
from the top we can trigger a top
collision and if none of those have held
true we know that we have had a
collision of some kind we can just
register a bottom collision and so this
is a simple version of this sort of way
of doing breakout collision it has
a few faults when it comes to corners
sometimes corners can be a little bit
finicky but I would say it works in 99%
of the time for a more much more robust
and better example I would look at this
URL here because he also goes into a
full sort of breakdown of how he would
implement Arkanoid which is the same
thing effectively as break out if you
just want an alternative look at it but
basically his solution involved taking
how much the X and the y differed on
different points of the bricks relative
to the the ball and I believe he also
kept the ball as an actual ball with a
center point even though he rendered it
as a as a rectangle so it's a little bit
a little bit more robust I decided to
implement a simpler way which I'll
showcase which is the way that I
demonstrated because it worked well and
did wasn't too much code to sort of look
over them but I do encourage you to take
a look at that we're gonna look at our
play state now and break out for
and in our play state we're gonna see
oops sorry line 65 so this is the actual
paddle code for influencing the balls
Delta X so basically if the ball dot X
is less than the paddle dot X plus its
width divided by two so basically on the
left side of the paddle and of the
paddles Delta X is less than zero which
means it's moving the left because we
don't really want to necessarily
influence it if we're just standing
still we're gonna do what I described
earlier we're going to give it some
scalar like some start off value in this
case negative 50 is just a sort of
seating this giving it some sort of
initial value and then we're just going
to subtract the balls X from the middle
point this being the middle point of the
paddle and then just multiply it by
eight so whatever that difference is
between the paddle or between the balls
X in the middle of the paddle multiply
it by eight add it to negative fifty and
then negate that also negate that whole
value so that the whole entire value
becomes negative and we therefore get a
sharper Delta X depending on which angle
it's come in at and also how fast or not
how fast but whether or not we're moving
left it's the exact same thing on the
right side only because we're taking the
this math of the self dot powell dot X
plus self dot paddle dot width divided
by two minus the ball dot X the ball dot
X is going to be greater than that point
so this had values actually going to be
negative so we're gonna just make it
positive with math.abs so absolute value
just a lua function so the absolute
value of the difference between the
balls X and the middle point times eight
add it to fifty and that'll give us a
positive value that scales depending on
whether or not we've hit the middle of
the we've hit the right edge of the
paddle and are moving to the right and
so that's in a nutshell how we get the
collision to work with the paddle and
how we can tweak Delta X to be scaled a
little bit more than just a constant
you know negative or whatever its
current ex was but negative dy a little
bit more complicated and then the actual
collision code for the bricks themselves
is gonna take place in a four loop here
so if it's in play if the ball collides
with it hit it so I added plus two so
the gist of the math is if ball dot X is
less than brick dot X and the ball is
moving to the right self top ball that
DX is greater than zero then flip its X
velocity so bounce it to the left that's
what this check is but it plays a little
bit rough with corners because you could
theoretically get into a position where
you come in at an angle and then it's
intersecting with the it's intersecting
with the paddle in two positions both on
top and the left or on bottom and the
left
so in that case adding two sort of
prioritizes the Y being hit so it
basically takes the check from the x
position of the ball to the X plus two
and so we and so it ends up fixing the
corners a little bit but the gist of it
is just check to see if the ball dot X
is less than the brick dot X and if it
is and we've detected a collision we can
bounce it so there are some subtle
corner kicks bugs without adding this
plus two so we add that and then flip
the velocity here oh this shift here
this is what we're talking about earlier
with make sure when you do a collision
shift whatever is moving outside the
boundaries of whatever you're colliding
with so self dot ball dot X gets brick X
minus eight because the ball is eight
pixels wide this should actually be self
dot ball dot width for a better style
but that's essentially what it
translates out to same thing for the
right edge the plus six because it's on
the right side so it's effectively the
same thing as minus two if we're on the
left side just a course just sort of
fixes corners weird issues with corners
but checking to see if the basically
that ball plus its height minus two is
greater than
the brick plus X plus brick dot width
which it means oh we've collided with
the right edge of the screen of the of
the brick and then if the y is less than
the brick dot y then we've collided with
the top of the brick and otherwise we've
collided with the bottom and with the
top and the bottom just do the same
thing we did with Delta X but do it with
Delta Y but you're still resetting it so
ball dot Y gets picked up Y minus eight
ball dot y gets brick that y plus 16
because the paddle or the individual
bricks are 16 pixels tall that's the
gist of the collision detection and then
if we actually oh and one other thing
that I ended up putting here just to
make it a little bit more interesting
and this also ties into more complicated
collision detection if your velocity is
too fast a lot of the time it'll skip
through objects and then that causes a
lot of problems with these collision
detection functions that normally are
very sort of mathematically correct and
they work well they don't work well when
it skips over what you're trying to
actually collide with so a solution to
that which was beyond the scope of this
example but something worth thinking
about is perhaps stepping backwards a
certain amount of time a certain amount
of pixels perhaps maybe start at where
you where your ball was on one
particular on the last frame and then
just add its width and height to itself
until it collides with something until
it reaches whatever its current Delta X
or Delta Y plus its position is that's
one way to do it sort of just adding a
bunch of invisible sum whatever you're
colliding with or whatever you're using
to collide add a bunch of invisible
those to bridge the gap and check until
if any of those hold true for a
collision a little bit more
computationally inexpensive but a lot
more accurate in terms of the physics
and aside from that everything is the
same so if you look at the code in
breakout 4 and I'm gonna go a little bit
faster henceforth that's the probably
the medius part of the program
we get collisions and then I'll try and
get a strong angle so I can demo the
that didn't work that actually gave a
weaker angle so if you if you do this
and you do it close to the center as the
opposite effect but there we go that's a
sharper angle so now you can actually
influence the ball and a little bit more
of a personable way and you know not
just have it be a flat Delta Y gets
negative Delta or go up negative Delta Y
effectively so any questions on sort of
how the gist of all that works okay
perfect
so now we're going to get into a little
bit more of some fun stuff we'll do a
couple more examples and we'll take a
break so this is the hearts update so
notice that the very top of the screen
as I've demonstrated in these slides we
have just a few hearts one of them is
empty we showed this earlier and then we
have a game over screen which shows us
our final score so I'm gonna go ahead
and we're just gonna look at the code a
little bit faster now since a lot of the
stuff is fairly straightforward I'm
gonna go ahead and open up the and make
sure I'm in the right folder first of
all break out five and then in the so
one another thing we're gonna start
doing is I mentioned this earlier and
it's gonna be it's gonna hold true for
any of the sort of state transformations
that take place going forward rather
than keep global variables we're gonna
sort of do away with that idea outside
of the asset tables that we have just
because those are kind of an exception
and they could reasonably be put into a
separate class called the resource
manager we're going to have a we're
going to start passing in what is our
basically our current app state or at
least the variables that make sense and
this is a common paradigm in web
development with react as well but
basically everything that we need to
like preserve state to state rather than
just keeping global variables let's
passed them between the states because
the state machine allows us to do that
in the change function and then whatever
that state is in its enter function
it'll have access to that and it can
just set those values to self dot
whatever
and use them but we no longer have
global variables we're just saying here
here's the values that are important for
you to you know continue on and then
that state will take its values and go
to the next state and say oh okay here
are the values that you need to you know
function like the serve play and all
those states that have the core gameplay
involved we'll probably need to maintain
a reference to like the paddle into the
score the amount of health we have but
when we get to the end for example and
then we no longer really need a paddle
we no longer really need you know bricks
or anything like that we just need to
know what our high score is so that we
can enter it into the into our high
score list all we really need to do is
just pass in the high score state entry
or just our high score and that's it so
it encapsulates all of our data and at a
glance we can sort of see what we need
to pass between the states and like
what's going to be relevant at a glance
as well it just cleaned things up quite
a bit so that's that's what we're doing
now in online 35 and henceforth we will
do this in every state as we see but I'm
gonna sort of glaze over in the future
we have a serve state now so a serve
state this is very identical to what we
did in pong so we just wait for the user
to press space they can move around and
then when they do press Enter basically
they the ball starts moving and then we
changed the play state here using the
current values that are necessary paddle
breaks health score and ball those are
basically the fundamental variables that
we need in order to keep track of our
game state so we have a serve state
it'll wait for us to press enter and
then our main Lua we have a new Hearts
table
and then online 208 because we have
we're going to need the ability to
render health and render our score
across several states play serve victory
game over
actually not game over but the three
before that we don't want to duplicate
this behavior so I'm just calling a
function called render health which just
takes in whatever a health is and then
we just set it an X 2 virtual with minus
100 and then for however many health we
have draw a heart from the hearts sprite
sheet which the I separated the hearts
out into a smaller image so you can just
split them on like 8 by 8 or whatever it
is but just draw those and then add 11
to X and just keep going until we've
drawn out however many hearts we have
that'll draw full hearts and then 3
minus health will give us however many
health were missing so if we took a
point of damage this is gonna be equal
to 1 so then draw it'll draw 1 empty
heart after that or draw two empty
hearts so draw however make full hearts
we have then draw the empty hearts and
those are two separate sprites that we
get from the from the image and that'll
have the effect of drawing our health
and then our score is simply it takes a
score variable that we get that would
pass into it here and also note that the
render health takes a health variable we
pass into it here and so in our play
state we are calling both of these
functions
on line 135 well on one through on line
135 we are calculating whether we go
below the edge of the screen which is
another important part of the game
obviously we need to detect when we've
lost health so it's as simple as this if
it's greater than the virtual height
decrement health by one if it's equal to
zero change to game over else change to
the Serb state and note that we're
passing in all these variables to and
from our states the ones that are
important game over just needs score but
serve needs whatever variables we were
already using and then down here we're
calling render score and render health
and then the game over state is simply
because it takes in score from the
parameters list just wait for keyboard
input to go back to the start and then
render game over here's your score it's
self dot score and then that's it very
simple very simple state sure
the question was do any of these states
have access to their parent file is
everything in main.lua
global functions yes functions that you
declare anything that's basically not
specified as local that you define a
main doubt Lua will be accessible
anywhere in your application including
functions you don't have to question
what you have to declare as public no
there is no notion of public Lua in Lua
anything that does not have a local
specifier is assumed global even if it's
in a nested scope so you could have a
for loop you could have several nested
for loops and declare some variable
without local that variable can be
accessed anywhere above it or outside of
it so it's pretty important to use local
variables when you're not explicitly out
allocating something as global just to
avoid the bug of for loop nested loops
in you have some variable named like
hello and you use it somewhere else
good questions though so yeah we have a
bunch of states now we have a game over
state a play state we're rendering our
score rendering our health if we go and
take a look at breakout 5 is it in a
different window there we go
we can see hearts at the top score zero
oh and I forgot to mention the part
where we actually add score now so the
brick themselves in there on hit or I
should say in the play state on line 81
when we detect a hit we're just adding
10 to the score for now but later on
we'll do a calculation where we take
tear and color into consideration and
then perform our arithmetic on that to
get our total score for each ball hit
well yeah we're generating we have our
health we have our score and then once
we take enough damage we'll end up going
to the game over screen the game over
screen we'll go back to our Start screen
so making progress and then probably my
favorite of the updates before we take a
short break is the pretty colors update
so what this does is clearly we can have
we've updated our level maker so rather
than just having a bunch of very static
bricks we end up doing a little bit more
complicated procedural generation it's
not complicated though it just in level
maker Lua in breakout 6 we have a few
different constants here so solid
alternate skip or none actually don't
think I use skipper none just solder
alternate basically we have flags now so
number of columns and we ensure that
it's odd because even columns with with
generating patterns leads to a symmetry
so make sure the number of columns is
odd generate a highest here and a
highest color based on our level so in
this case we will go no higher of a tier
than 3 because that we have no higher
tiers than 3 we go 0 1 2 3 and then
whatever our level divided by 5 is and
then we just take math off floor mat for
takes in basically performing division
and then truncating the decimal point on
that division it just literally
translates the decimal point off of a
number so level divided by 5 whatever
that is before the decimal point level
modulo 5 plus 3 for the highest color so
we'll cycle will go over and over again
go highest color 1 2 3 4 5 and then
we'll go to a new tier with level
divided by 5 so basically every 5
we'll increment in tier and then we'll
start back at blue and then go on and on
and on like that for every number of
rows so basically I have a few I'm gonna
sort of glaze over this a little bit I'm
just because we're probably gonna run
short on time but we have basically two
flags whether we skipping bricks in this
row or alternating bricks color wise and
if we do we need to set a color for it
and a tier and then we basically just
say you know the same sort of logic that
we had before where we generated random
rows and columns but if we're if we have
the alternate flag on then as we can see
in some of these photos here here we
have skip is true so the color for that
row is set to the blue but skip is true
so every other brick it's just gonna
skip that iteration of the loop same
thing here only it's offset by one same
thing here same thing here so this is
kind of a nice little pattern and in
each of these cases are actually not
each of these cases notice this third
one it also set alternate to true so it
goes green purple green purple green
purple and so the logic there is if
Altan it's true then just flip the color
every iteration if skip is true don't
generate a brick every other iteration
and so on and so forth and then if you
have solid then or if you don't have
alternate equals true then you have a
solid brick like these blue ones and if
you have noce if you have alternate but
no skip you get this sort of pattern
where you have green purple green purple
you know any random color and then also
the number of columns is random so it
can go you know here we have 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 but on this neck this very
bottom one we have that minus 2 it looks
like because it can only go only goes
that wide and so I notice here two
smaller size that one there's no spacing
so three these are very simple concepts
like just should we skip a block this
iteration should we alternate the colors
and when you put them all together it
produces things that look as if they
were almost handcrafted like this could
be made by somebody like that looks like
it was made by somebody pretty much
every iteration of this I mean even that
looks like a shape almost it's just very
simple but the results are
pretty awesome in my opinion and so
that's just the gist behind what we're
doing we're just setting flags and just
saying you know if we're skipping this
turn then just every iteration every
time we lay out of brick and we spawn a
new brick on this row just do or don't
just make its color you know pick two
colors if we're alternating and then set
its color to whatever the off color is
that we're alternating and if we're
skipping and alternating then we're just
doing whenever we're on a brick that
were actually laying is when we changed
the color the alternate color and so
like I said I won't go into too much
detail happy to talk about the generator
after class but just because we're
running short on time sort of gonna wave
my hands over it but that's it in a
nutshell so any questions before we take
a break for five minutes yes
the question is in an instance with this
programming if the ball were so fast
that it were actually inside the brick
would it what when it still bounced back
the answer is no it wouldn't this
implementation doesn't take into
consideration velocity that goes too
fast mainly to introdu reasons one it's
non trivial to implement and two it's an
interesting thing to look at and observe
and be conscious of as you go forward
and implementing your own games the
current code if it gets clipped inside
of the the brick it will have no edges
that are peeking outside of the brick
and therefore will default to the final
condition which is the last else clause
which puts it below the brick so it'll
just go below the brick it'll it'll
almost be as if it bounced it came in
from the from the underside and bounced
out but like I alluded to earlier if you
want to implement something like this
yourself you would have to slice up a
frame X and frame X plus one into the
size of the ball if the Delta is so wide
that it either goes inside of a brick or
it goes outside of a brick or if it
skips a brick and this sort of solves
that problem it solves both of those
problems
but it's a little more than we can cover
in this example any other questions
all right let's take five and get back
to it all right and we're back so the
next step is we have basically a layout
dynamically generated of interesting
bricks now but we haven't really
implemented scoring any of these we just
have score gets score plus 10 which
isn't really particularly interesting so
break out seven is what I call the tier
update which will should allow us to hit
blocks that are of a higher tier than
just base blue and if they are of a
higher color than base blue they should
go down a color so the hierarchy was if
we look back blue goes to green goes to
red goes to purple goes to Gold and if
something is a higher tier it goes to
the next color below it but at that same
T
unless it happens to be like blue and
gray and then in which case it'll go
back to blue so how might we implement
scoring based on this system what do we
need what pieces do we need what pieces
do we already have that we can use to
make this happen I'm sorry
so the answer was the brick index so yes
the brick skin and color are the pieces
yeah so those are fields of brick so if
we open up I'm gonna go up to break out
seven and I'm gonna start probably
differing a lot of this code to future
reading but in brick here the tier and
the color sorry not the skin but skin is
for the for the paddle but the brick has
a tier and it has a color and so we just
need to perform some arithmetic on that
here and that's essentially what lines
44 through 58 is so basically I
apologize that's not actually where the
arithmetic is 44 that does compute but
this is what this is the bit of code
that computes how we can actually go
backwards if we make a collision so if
we collide with a brick and it's of a
higher tier than you know one and it's a
higher color than blue it should be
brought back one step but if it happens
to be blue in which case self dot color
gets one because blue is one then it
should just be removed from play just
like we've done before only now we're
also taking in tier and color so we're
decrementing tier based on what index
we're at and we're decrementing color
and then this actually gets used in our
play state if we go to
line an 81 which previously just had
self-doubts courgettes self-doubt score
plus one there's a little bit of math
here it's very simple though just react
air times 200 so I'll make the tiers
worth 100 + brick color times 25 and so
if tier is zero if it's a base then
we're just not gonna get that 200 bonus
but the first tier everything's gonna be
worth 25 times whatever its color is so
1 2 3 4 5 and then add 200 + the brick
color for when we get to the next set of
bricks and so the result of this is Lee
this is go a breakout 7 and then if we
hit a brick since this one's blue it
should disappear and we're playing a new
sound as well a new like death sound
just to make it clear but notice they
change colors so that's all we're doing
we're just taking their tier or their
color and it's performing a simple
decrement on it looping back in the
event that we go down a tier we should
loop back up to the highest color of the
lower tier so I'll let you look at the
code for that if you want to sort of get
a more low-level understanding of it but
that's the sort of high level
understanding the next big concept that
I'd like to introduce you guys to is a
particle system and so particle systems
are fairly um - present in video games I
would say because they make effects that
are otherwise difficult to do with
simple sprite editing achievable very
easily and realistically just like fire
for example things that are very organic
and flowy and have a lot going on are
often better represented with particle
systems than they are with the simple
sprite animation so does anybody know
how we might be able to how a sprite a
particle system might work underneath
the hood I think I alluded to it
previously
yes
yeah so what he said was in order to
make fire for example just spawn a bunch
of particles close to the center of
wherever your fire responding and then
outside of it spawn fewer that is
absolutely a way to to get fire to work
and also taking into consideration just
the the the travel of your particles for
example you might spawn a ton of fire
particles really densely but then maybe
they have some logic that makes them go
upwards maybe they have a negative Delta
Y and then some sort of acceleration so
it sort of trail off and then maybe sort
of how to get a more realistic fire look
they travel sort of upwards and then
fade away so this way fireworks sort of
thinking of things in terms of particles
like that you can achieve a lot of
effects how might we implement like
smoke for example same system
so we could have maybe like a timer you
know in our particle effect or even a
transition because in particle systems
often you have the ability to transition
colors between particles let's say you
start off red go to yellow and then
maybe your particle system transitions
to gray or brown and then over time your
particles are going up they're
dissipating and they're also turning
dark
they're turning brown it sort of gives
you the illusion of fire and we won't be
doing anything necessarily as complex as
this in our code here but in breakout 8
we will be using love loves sort of
integrated particle system which is just
love graphics that new particle system
and it takes in a texture because all
particle systems need some sort of
texture as their foundation and then it
needs the number of particles that it
could maximally emit and so each
individual particle system can emit up
to a certain instance of particles and
then the number and speed and whatnot of
all those particles is ultimately the
determining factor for how you can get
an illusion you know back to last week's
lecture illusions like it's not fire
it's not smoke it's just a bunch of
particles responding with colors and
acceleration and stuff but there's a lot
of functions that particle system gives
you in left to D so I encourage you to
look at that link just to explore some
of them love to the org slash wiki slash
particle system will be using a few of
them here I'm going to just briefly show
you so each individual brick when it
gets hit it's going to eat a particle
system of its own because our goal is
I'll rent or run the code for you so you
can see it so if you go to breakout
eight and let me run it we have
a little bit of content a little bit of
particles you saw that at the very end
the blue ones you were probably able to
see a little bit better and then one
last time so it spawns a bunch of little
particles so can anyone tell me what how
they think the particles are behaving
sort of in a nutshell what the logic is
for the particles
yeah slightly random and if you look at
it you'll also notice that they tend to
go downwards so knowing that we can
probably just assume that there have an
acceleration that tends towards positive
Y and that's essentially all we really
need to do we spawn a bunch of particles
outwards and then just set them they
have a lifetime they last for you know a
certain amount of time and then they
fade between two colors in this case we
fade from red to transparent or whatever
color it is and then after the lifetime
has elapsed the part it has the overall
effect of sort of this glimmering
gravity-based effect but it's really
just a bunch of particles that are set
to spawn in different directions
apologize for that so we'll take a look
it's gonna be in our BRIC class here and
break out eight so we're gonna go to
brick we have a bunch of colors that
we're storing here so if you notice the
particle systems adopt the color of
whatever brick they're hitting just so
that it stays sort of congruent with
what we're looking at so we're just
storing a bunch of colors here and these
are I wouldn't worry too much about this
these are just colors from the sprite
palette that we used with our sprite art
there's specific colors that are only
used in that sprite and having a palette
generally speaking allows your art to
look a little bit more cohesive when
you're doing sprite art as opposed to
just picking colors willy-nilly if you
say oh I'm gonna only use the 16 or 32
colors for this palette you'll sort of
have a more cohesive look and also a
very retro look because often hardware
was limited to a certain amount of
colors back in the day for older systems
so it's nice to as an aside and we'll
look at it next week as well looking at
when you're doing your own sprite art
try to use fewer colors and then that'll
give you it also makes it easier for you
you don't have to spend time choosing
you know oh I want to have this shade of
green I wonder if it looks good if you
only have two shades of green or semi
shades of green to choose from then
that's all you've got you have to make
do with it what you can so what we're
doing here is restoring five colors from
our palette we're going to use this and
then
when we trigger our so right here we're
initializing a particle system so P
system gets loved graphics that new
particle system and then these are a few
functions so you look and feel free to
look in the wiki for how these functions
actually behave but lifetime
acceleration and area spread just are
sort of the properties that influence
the way our particle systems behave and
so using whatever our current color is
we're going to set our P systems colors
using set colors function we're going to
set it between two colors color with 55
times T R alpha and color with zero
alpha so the higher the tier the
brighter the particles but they'll
always fade to zero alpha if that makes
sense and then we'll just emit 64 and
this is all in the hit function so all
we've basically done is just add this
particle system trigger in our hit
function and it has the result of the
behavior that we saw earlier so any
questions on particle systems or how
we've used them all right so level 9 is
the progression update so the purpose of
this update is to allow us to go from
level 1 to 2 to 3 to 4 and start get
more interesting level generation that
way the gist of this is in R so if you
look at our start state so
all we need to really do to store a
level is just to store a number and then
where do we increment the number or when
do we increment the number I should say
exactly so we set the we increment the
level we go to the next level when all
of the bricks that are in play have
gotten there in play flag set to false
so we have no bricks that are in play
effectively
so in our starts date so let's go ahead
and look at breakout nine so start state
we're passing a level gets one here
we're just gonna start off when we're
going to start State we're just gonna
pass the level equals 1 and then
henceforth any time we do any state
changes from play to serve and to
victory as we'll see victory being our
new oh you completely cleared this level
here's the next level where it's going
to pass the level between them and then
in play state the important bit of code
here is on line 204 so this is just a
function called check victory which is
exactly as James said you're going to
set where it's going to iterate over the
entire table and just say if it's in
play return false because we're not in
victory if we have any bricks that are
in play but return true if we didn't
meet that condition and so this is just
a simple way for us to check whether or
not we are in a victory and so on line
eighty-eight of the same file in our
play state we're checking to say hey if
self dot check victory after we do any
brick hit because that's when we've just
set a brick to in place false just check
victory and if so play a new sound like
a happy sound that we've done a victory
and then just pass everything into the
new victory state that we have here and
the victory state is simply a sort of
just a message state so all it does just
render renders everything as before but
it just says your current level complete
right self dot level complete and then
press enter to serve and it'll go back
to the serve state as soon as that
happens and then here is where the
actual like progression happens when we
go to the serve state we have our level
but we want to add one to it so all I
need to do when we go when we like
trigger a transition into our next state
just increment level by one here and
also create a new map because bricks
needs to get restarted because we have a
new level self dot level plus one and so
that will have the effect of oh we have
a we've gone from level 1 to 2 to 3 to 4
etc when we go between play state to the
victor
stay back to the serve state so any
questions on how any of this works yes
garbage collection is handled by love
yes yeah yes because the question was do
you have to worry about garbage
collection when we are sort of clearing
away the bricks and adding new bricks
the self bricks table this table here
it's getting assigned to a brand new
table from level map create map when
there are no references to an existing
table Louis garbage collector will
trigger at whatever interval that's set
to trigger and clear up all that for you
dynamically just like the same way that
Java works almost identical mhm any
other questions
all right so we have progression in the
sake of speed I won't demo but and it
also takes a while just because we have
to clear an entire level then get to the
next level but that's how the behavior
works the next sort of iteration of this
is high scores and I will test to make
sure whether or not this is actually
working
I know I changed some stuff yeah so okay
high score let's debug for a second so
high score state line 38 in breakout 10
so high score state and then the issue
was attempt to index field high scores
and nil value okay so that means that
okay I think I think I might know the
issue but it's because I transition to a
new user that doesn't have a save file
active on this the way that I will
transition therefore into love that file
system which is break out tens main new
things that it introduces so writing
files to your file system is done
through you with love dot file system
and there's a few things so love
automatically gives you a directory a
save directory that you that's pretty
much hard-coded there are a few
exceptions as to how to like not use
that directory but it assumes that
you're always using that directory and
for very few exceptions will you with
few very few exceptions will you always
use that folder it's like AppData local
on windows and application support and
the name of your application on mac but
it's a subfolder that love has read and
write access to for files on your file
system you can check whether it exists
with loved-up file system that exists at
some path you can write to that path
with some data that data being a string
value and then love that file system dot
lines is an iterator which will allow
you to look over any of the data that's
in a file at a given location yes yep
it should we can pull that up now
actually and see because I know on their
love to D so file system so the question
was he ported his can you when you pour
a your love app to the iPhone will it
have the same sort of behavior if you're
on an iPhone will it have the same sort
of saved director behavior and it looks
like it's not officially on here I know
that there is a iOS port for love 2d or
the ability to send it to love 2d I have
to imagine yes it probably has some sort
of I'm not entirely familiar with how i
OS handles sort of local storage but I'm
assuming that just in the way that it's
been abstracted for desktops and for
Android it's also abstracted for iOS
haven't tested it myself
I would experiment and see actually
maybe with this with this code see if
you can maybe get it working with
persistent high scores I know that iOS
does typically let you store a small
amount of data per app in some location
a fixed location but I'm not entirely
sure what that is offhand I can look
into it more and come up with a yeah I
mean not from first hand because I don't
have an Android but it has official
Android support so I'm guessing it does
but I haven't tested it I have not
tested to manually on Android to verify
that
but yes I have to believe because in the
prior directory we're looking at where
when it showed oh it's actually up here
this this path here this data slash user
slash zero dot org love 2d Android file
save that looks to me like it's the
official sort of path that data is
stored on an Android device for your
application
so haven't tested it myself but if you
have an Android and you're curious or
maybe an emulator maybe give it a shot
and see if it works oh and it even says
here there are various save locations
and if they don't work you can see what
the actual location is with this
function here the loved-up file system
that gets saved directory that may work
on iOS as well so I'd be curious to hear
about whether that actually works on
that but yeah so that's the gist using
the love dot file system abstraction
lets us read and write files we can then
just paste or we can just save whatever
data we want anywhere within that
directory we can just create files in
there and then use those to store our
you know sort of game worlds or
character profiles or whatnot how would
we maybe go about implementing sort of
like high score list
so we have so I'll look there's a
picture here so we have ten scores we'll
assume that's fixed each of the scores
has a name and then each of the scores
has an actual score so all we really
need to do is just store ultimately the
names and then the scores
so we use an array their response was
we'll use an array and sort it by that
score yeah essentially that's exactly it
we're just gonna keep a score table and
each table is gonna have a sub table and
each of those entries one through ten is
gonna have a name and a score and then
once we're done with their application
will just use love dot file system dot
right we have to convert all of those
into a string right because we can't
just take a table and then spit that out
into a file and we have to actually make
it into some form that we can save and
then reload back in somehow what would
be the most efficient way do you think
or a way we could do this
probably just a new line separated list
I would the way that I've done it in
this application is just names and then
new line score new line name new line
score ten so 20 rows and that gets the
job done assuming that you don't tamper
with the file then everything should
work and you can write additional code
as well to say oh there's if there is a
score that's all garbled we don't have
enough scores then probably should
render it accordingly my code does
something similar to this but not
entirely the relevant code and I'm gonna
sort of just glaze over it if we're
looking at this is breakout 11 right
yeah oh no this is breakout 10 so in
breakout 10 we have to load all the high
scores in main Lua which is here so set
identity to breakout or as create a
folder called breakout that we can save
and read files to and from if it doesn't
exist then just create them in this case
I'm just seating CTO my initials and
then I times a thousand so 10,000 down
to 1000 just very simple data writing it
to a file called break up that LST can
be whatever you want all we're doing is
reading the lines from the data or from
the file and then this is if it doesn't
exist and then if it does exist then
we're going to iterate over it with love
dot file system dot lines which will
take a file and then just every it'll
just split it on new lines basically and
give you an iterator over all those
lines so I can just say okay if it's a
name which means that if it's 1 or 3 or
5 or 7 in the list then set the name to
and we're using string dot sub just in
case they write some long name or some
long name guess we can't do it through
our game but if it gets written to the
file as some long name
it should get truncated to 3 character
so we can display it appropriately and
then otherwise if we're not on a name
line if we're on like an odd line then
we should write even line we should
consider that a score and just like use
2 number because right we're using
string data and if we try to assign like
do any sort of comparisons numerically
on the string data which we will have to
do to compare high scores it's not going
work because it's gonna see if their
strings so we use to number here just a
simple Lua function and then that's it
and then we just return scores and then
I'll sort out what the it's causing the
issue and then push that to the to the
repo ASAP but that has the effect of us
being able to actually load all of our
high scores and display them at the
start of the game it doesn't take care
of being able to actually input our
score and so we can do this with
breakout eleven which you can see if you
run the repo and you can to test just
assign your initial score to some value
like 10,000 or 20,000 and then just lose
on purpose and you'll get a sense of how
it actually works
but essentially it's just arcade style
you know you had only three characters
you could input your name so does
anybody have any idea as to how we are
sort of storing this or can pitch an
idea so we have three characters and we
want to ideally if we're we look let's
say I want to go to C on the first one
and you know I put a I press up twice so
I get to see how is it going from A to C
you could just say you could just render
I want to render the character a the
character a the character a but that's
not really gonna how's it gonna know
when you want to go to B or to see or to
D
the pitch was you could create a table
with all of the characters in iterate
through it you absolutely could do that
it's a little bit bulky that might be
what Ashley that's probably not how our
Cade systems did it back in the day
because the way that we're gonna do it
here in breakout 11 or is it be kinda
let us break out 11 is I added a new
state called enter high score state and
if you recall cs50 teaches this but you
know all sort of characters at the end
of the day are just numbers ASCII in
this case 65 if you recall is capital a
so all we need to do is just draw out
whatever that character cast to a string
is or a character and when we do that
simply down here in the draw function if
we do string dot care string that char
at chars 3 all that all that has the
effect of doing is just taking that
number and then can bring it to a
character so all we need to do then is
what when we want to we'll go from A to
B B to C C to D exactly but then what
happens if write a and we want to go
down
heywood so if we're at a then we
probably if we press down we're gonna
want to go to Z the logic is in here but
if you know
once we've increment increment at our
code m is greater than 9 B which is Z
then we should set it back to 65 let's
loop back to a and same thing here if we
press down and we're at a we probably
got to go back up to Z so we're just set
it to 90 so a simple loop bat-logic
and we just draw it we highlight and
then once we've done that the user
presses enter we transition to the high
score state actually because this state
should only trigger if they entered a
new high score which means that we need
to check
the victory state or not the victory
state but rather in the GAMEOVER state
whether or not their score is higher
than any of the stores in some sort of
quote unquote Global scores table and
then how do we think we're passing the
scores back and forth now does anybody
recall how we're keeping track of
appstate
yep in the change function so all we
need to do is keep track of our load or
high scores at the beginning of the game
pass them all the way down the line and
then finally and we could also load them
in our enter high score state but we
need to keep track of what our high
scores are in the game over state so
that we know oh I got a high score let's
instead of transitioning back to the
start state let's transition to the
enter high score state so the user can
add their high score to the list and
then once they've entered their high
score oops just here well just write it
to this file again we compiled a score
string which just takes name and score
of our scores we take whatever score
that we were at that's what we we look
through our scores table backwards and
when we find a score that's hired or
that's lower than ours we just keep
track of that index until we get to one
that's higher than ours in which case
the one plus one that index plus one is
what we should then overwrite and so we
shift all the other ones below
accordingly and we do that in this class
if curious and so I'm just gonna breeze
through the last couple the paddle
select update is just kind of a fluffy
state that lets us add a element of sort
of like user selection to our game in
our paddle select state here we
transition immediately instead of going
to this to the surface a play state now
we're going to go from start to paddle
select when we hit start game so we're
gonna go to and then the paddle select
class itself current paddle gets one and
then all it centrally is is us drawing
two arrows here and so if we're at
number one in this case I think we're at
numbers number three then both of these
arrows will be completely opaque but if
we're on the left of the right edge they
should darken to say to us oh we can't
move left to right anymore because we're
at either index 1 or 4 4 5 and there's
only that many colors and then render
whatever that color variable is you know
using the the quads table that we had
before of the
different tables and then just
instructions and then from there is
where we'll end up transitioning to the
serve state rather than going to the
serve state from the start state and all
the code in that is here we have sound
effects playing and then making sure
that we also play a different sound
effect based upon whether they're at the
left of the right edge if are on the
left edge and they try to go left it
should play like a sound that sort of
sounds a little rougher to let them know
that they can't go left and the opposite
for the right edge and then once that's
all done go to the once they press Enter
on whatever paddle they want they're
gonna get the paddle they're gonna stand
she ate a paddle pass that into the
serve state and we're gonna take current
paddle from the state which is whatever
value they got by scrolling between the
all the different paddles and then the
last update which is my favorite part of
most every lecture I think is the music
update and all that really is is just
music set play and in main Lua
and then set looping to true and then we
have a game and this is our paddle
select so recall like notice the arrows
are semi-opaque on the left and the
right and it's kind of hard to hear but
when I press right now it's kind of like
there's a bit of a rougher sound we
choose red we go to level one we've
transitioned to the surf state from the
paddle select state and then we just
play the game as normal and that's
basically all there is to it and there's
a couple features you can have time to
really go over like like making sure we
recover HP if a certain amount of points
have been elapsed but I encourage you to
look into that
when you trigger a hit there's some
logic in the in a place date to say oh
if they've gone over a current like
recovery threshold let's add one heart
to the player you know just to keep them
playing just to reward them for their
high score next time
we'll cover a few concepts of basic
shaders shaders are like little programs
you can run in a graphics card to do
fancy effects but won't go into too much
detail anonymous functions we've seen a
lot of anonymous functions in Lua and
the
context of love they're just functions
without a name and you can just use them
as function arguments and do all sorts
of cool stuff with them we'll use them
for callbacks in next week when we do
things like tweening which is taking
some value and making it interpolate
over time to some other thing because
right now we basically just been
updating things based on velocity but we
haven't really done anything based on
time so we'll take a look at that in
more detail next week with a library
called timer which is really fantastic
let's do time things and then chain
things together we'll be covering the
game match-three if familiar it's
basically candy crush I'll be using a
different tile set but it's the same
idea and we'll have to calculate how to
actually find out whether we've gotten a
match in the grid our tile grid and then
shift the blocks accordingly and do all
the other logic add score and then
basically it's since it's so fundamental
to candy crush in games of its nature we
will have to cover how to sort of
generate these Maps procedurally to have
tiles that are laid out in a dynamic way
and also in a way that doesn't start off
with any matches because then that
wouldn't make any sense because the
matches have to resolve and then we'll
take a little it'll take a little time
if we have the time next week to talk
about sprite are again in palettes and
maybe I'll show you guys how to sort of
convert images from one palette to
another in like a program that I use a
sprite but you can do this in any sort
of large photo editing software and then
assignment 2 is a couple of extensions
to assignment or to breakout so if you
noticed in the sheet there were a few
little sprites here at the bottom so you
get rid of the quad outlines so these
little things down here are I'm assuming
their power meant to be power-ups they
look like power-ups but the goal of the
pset is to implement a powerup and the
powerup is going to be such that when
you grab it you'll get two additional
balls or however many you want actually
that will spawn in addition to your one
and detect collisions on their own so
you'll have several and those score
points for you and of course only when
the last ball comes below the surface of
the screen should you trigger a game
over and then I want you to add on this
also be more detailed in the spec but I
would like you to add growing and
shrinking to the paddle so currently we
saw we have like four different sizes of
paddle but we're not using them so it
would be nice if when we gain enough
points or we lose points
are not points but lives rather we
increase or decrease the size of the
paddle accordingly just to introduce
another level of challenge and or lack
of challenge and then finally a one last
part which is in the spritesheet as well
there's a key block here and a key power
up here so sort of let the power up come
pick the power up up with your paddle
and then only when you have that power
up should you be able to break the block
with a key and you should take this into
consideration when generating your
levels as well so you'll have to also
get your hands dirty with the level
maker but all in all that was breakout
so I'll see you guys next time thank you